one of the most important tests that
we're going to do is the breaching test
reaching is sort of this ambush attack
you know they need speed power
stealth
this is when we're gonna be able to
measure the color of a great white shark
in its ultimate hunting mode
in the middle of mossel bay sits seal
island
this island's the epicenter for great
white sharks in south africa
[Music]
every day
hundreds of fur seals swim for their
lives
[Music]
through a gauntlet of great whites the
great white sharks success rate and
hunting cape fur seals is almost 50
and that's really high for any predator
now with these sharks they've got very
specific areas where they want to hunt
and patrol and it's usually right
underneath the natural roots that the
seals are exiting and entering the
islands
ryan and gibbs are towing a decoy seal
in the hopes of encouraging sharks to
breach
it's about trying to capture the
breaching shark alongside a colour board
and being able to measure the colour of
that breaching shark
it's a quiet morning
but seal island rarely disappoints
oh there's a predation
natural predation right over there
oh still going for it
oh god
this is hot this is in trouble yeah he's
using the boat for cover and even though
the shaft missed on that first breech
scared that seal so much and it's now
hiding around the boat using it for
cover
the seal leads the shark right to the
decoy
oh yeah
got it
[Music]
the shark and the color board are
clearly in frame
it's the first successful breach of the
experiment it sends goosebumps down my
spine every time i mean you just can't
you can't help but feel emotional every
time you see it
sharks are here in numbers
there we go
seals
all
day
long just having to go at it
as the sun sets after a day of data
collection the team hopes for one last
breach
hit that spot hit that spot
all right we've lost the color board
we've lost the decoy dang it
because it's so dark the shark couldn't
even see which one he's going for it
again
[Music]
you